les attentats du 11 septembre ont frappé
new york en plein coeur de ses activités
causant même la fermeture complète de
ces bourses aspect dramatique de ce qui
s'est passé a très largement dominé de
l'avion quand même des centaines de
morts le problème par exemple d'un
manque de sens dans le contexte les
parcs new-yorkais ont décidé de fermer
pendant toute une semaine du jamais vu
dans l'histoire un certain nombre
d'opérateurs et leur client n'aurait pas
été en mesure d'agir sur la bourse alors
que d'autres auraient pu le faire ça
crée une inégalité qui étaient
totalement inacceptables
la réouverture lundi 7 septembre a
suscité beaucoup d'émotion à la fois une
tristesse profondes
de ce qui s'était passé
mais j'allais dire une rage de vivre un
besoin de recommencer nous ne pouvions
pas nous laisser abattre il fallait
remettre le marché en route il fallait
que l'économie se remette en route mais
avec l'incertitude le dow jones a perdu
7% la première journée et plus de 14%
durant la semaine mais choc dans
l'histoire c'est pas le premier mais ça
se repent dernier comme on vient de le
vivre et on est en train de revivre tous
les chocs sont similaires surprenant
imprévus et
on crée de l'instabilité en fait les
marchés étaient des gens correction avec
l'éclatement de la bulle technologique
l'événement servi de catalyseur ou
d'accélérateur de la correction quand un
événement comme ça arrive
concentrez-vous sur des bonnes
compagnies parce que les bonnes
compagnies finissent par passer à
travers c'est ce que vous voulez c'est
passé à travers la tempête
un mois plus tard les indices était déjà
revenue au niveau d'avant les attentats
l'autre autres grâce à l'intervention
musclée de la réserve fédérale
américaine qui a réduit les taux
d'intérêt et surtout injecter 200
milliards de liquidités dans le système
cherche à faire en sorte de créer
confiance sur les marchés qui éviter que
ça sept dormants qui choque plusieurs je
pense qu'on a été très efficace les
compagnies aériennes elles ont vu le
trafic aérien' plongé de 35% aux états
unis aujourd'hui quand on le compare
avec la pandémie ça nous paraît moins
important mais n'empêche qu'à l'époque
on n'avait jamais connu un tel
effondrement et on ne savait pas quoi
faire face à cet effondrement l'a
d'ailleurs à peine deux semaines après
les attentats le congrès accordé une
aide de 10 milliards à l'industrie
aérienne la majorité de ces compagnies
là qui ont dit qu'ils étaient en
difficulté qui sont demandé de l'aide au
gouvernement fédéral à l'époque il était
déjà en situation de difficultés
financières avant des attentats tous
secteurs confondus près de 200000
américains ont perdu leur emploi après
les attentats nous quelques mois plus
tard l'économie s'était déjà relevé
l'effet peau et est persistant a donc
c'est un choc était concentrée dans le
temps qui était beaucoup plus d'impact
pour la ville de new york qui était
beaucoup plus importante évidemment mais
en général
la relance américain n'a par contre
années certains changements structuraux
dans l'économie les attaques du 11
septembre ont accéléré peut-être des
phénomènes qui allait se produire de
toute façon mais les ont certainement
accéléré de mails ainsi la cession de
profits des entreprises devaient trouver
une solution pour
raviver les profits est une des
solutions c'est d'utiliser l'entrée de
la chaîne en louant le sait pour
faire une relocalisation de la
production
washington s'est aussi lancé dans une
déréglementation pour favoriser la
relance ça peut être mené à certains
excès que nos connue en 2005-2006
d'innovation financière qui est ami -
encadrer et qui a mené à cette
arrestation à de 2007-2008 soit la
grande récession
sans oublier que les états unis ont
dépensé depuis 2001 six mille milliards
de dollars pour la sécurité intérieure
et la lutte contre le terrorisme mais
c'est marie claude morin radio canada
montréal